when i buy the collection or when i get
the figure it's mainly for
for peace of mind and there's this whole
mentality of if i don't have a specific
figure
i cannot sleep
[Music]
my first collection was joe comics when
i think i was primary three i still
remember this very clearly i had a
really good friend uh he had this issue
of gi joe i thought it was really good
and the cover was cobra commander the
colours really popped
and then from there the love for
superheroes grew from that that comic
collection the tactileness of of a
figure or a statue is very special right
so when you when you see a character
let's say for example my favorite
character nightcrawler right so
looking at the image on the page
and holding it is two very different
things based off that feeling right i
decided that collecting action figures
fulfills a deeper need for
for that love than this print
hi my name is neil i'm 45 years old and
welcome to my superhero man cave
[Music]
oddly enough i didn't collect action
figures to begin with my first piece was
doctor doom the the whole idea of
collecting doctor doom was not so much
the character because i wasn't really
that
interested in doctor but the pose the
sculpting
the whole
essence of of how he looked was just
incredible he called out to me like i
could literally hear the voice on my
head to say you have to buy me
and at 14
you don't really have a lot of money the
shop i still remember it was a siglup
center
and the owner was very nice so when i
told the uncle hey
i really want this
is there any way i can do some sort of
like deposit kind of thing he was very
nice to me says okay little boy if you
want uh just pay me fifty dollars a
month i think after five months you can
get it so that's how i managed to get
drunk i don't really follow the
market prices because when i buy the
collection or when i get the figure it's
mainly for for peace of mind and there's
this whole mentality of if i don't have
a specific figure
i cannot sleep it will always be in my
mind trying to think about okay how do i
get this you know where can i go it's
always this little nagging doubt that
that keeps me awake at night most of it
is action figures are from a six inch
scale and most of my figures are from
from the dc sarah is either mattel or dc
direct
then for marvel is either
hasbro or marvel select
[Music]
currently i have a supplier
like a personal friend of mine right
here's the one that gonna get all this
action fitness so shout out to marvin
fool that gets all of my items from me
it's not so much a collection then it's
an obsession to me it's almost like a
drug every time i get a certain
item that has been hard to find i feel
this whole sense of
accomplishment
in the past there are certain figures
that because the way the company is sort
of distributed right there will be rare
figures that are so hard to find that
even though you search all around you
cannot find it and i was lucky enough
that
back then my work allowed me to travel
every time i travel i would visit all
the toy stores and find the figures that
singapore don't have
currently i have everything i need to
have for for marvel legends i have every
single figure produced back when it was
under toy biz in the late 90s and he
moved over to hasbro legends so i have
every single figure even the the
exclusive the variants while
during that period some of them were
really hard to get because i think
one of the ways was exclusive to like a
retailer in us that was really hard to
get even within the region you cannot
find
and this is back before the internet
days back before amazon that wave would
be the giant manual
you really got to
search high and low to find it which
eventually i managed to find i had to
pay a bit depending on prices at least
three to four times what would have gone
at retail
so the thing about collecting is uh how
you display them right collectors are
also hoarders right the only difference
between hoarders and collectors are that
the collectors are able to display them
in a very nice way and identify where
everything lies specifically
most of the items has a very special
emotional connection and memory attached
to it if you
point out to a specific figure right i
can probably tell you a bit more about
where i was what i was doing when i
purchased it to me story is also very
important it has to be
correct to that character's storyline if
you know the history of ghost rider
right so ghost rider rides a motorcycle
and because of his supernatural
abilities his motorcycle can go up
vertical surfaces power display the
ghost rider figures are all on vertical
sections spider-man is the easiest
because spider-man swings from building
the building so again if you look at all
the stuff you'll see
all the various spidermans
[Music]
swinging from location to location and i
also try not to duplicate my spider-man
in terms of the poses so every
spider-man has a unique pose that is
identifiable to his actions
[Music]
todd mcfarlane had a very unique
distinct style and whenever he drew
spider-man's web i don't throw anything
so i still have all the original
twisting ties it grew to a point where
he started to get out of hand and i
realized hey if i actually joined all
the twisty ties it looked almost
identical to top my talent swept
i had a really good friend back then he
was like a diy carpenter
he came in he suggested hey you know why
don't you put it on the ceiling you can
actually build like a walkway a catwalks
across
then i have all these walkways for
additional
collection and additional display
what i've learned is careful planning
and make sure that every figure can
stand on its own
so that when the figures are displayed
all by itself
it looks natural
i tend to arrange them by grouping again
it's always about the story so
if if like like we look at um
this this level here right so they're
all arranged according to their groups
so like the superman group the batman
group then the justice league justice
society then the magic users and then
so on and so forth how much is is it
worth about five years ago i did a rough
calculation everything's worth about 150
000 same altogether
one statue is about
300 to 350
right and i have about maybe four to 500
pieces
uh and then one action figure is about
let's say 20 to 30 i have about 2 000
now
i think i wouldn't sell anything
because these are the stuff that i
really want
if there's a fire i probably save myself
first
my rationale is money you can always
make
stuff you can always collect but health
family is one thing that you can never
replace right so
if i go in to take and i burn myself
then i cannot i cannot enjoy my other
collection in the future
personally
yes i feel like my life would be dollar
without the collection when i have uh
like a long day and i come here i sit
down and look at certain pieces it helps
me to to relax and
gives me peace of mind so that when i
look at a certain
range or you know certain grouping
the the mind naturally slows down and
any stress or problems that i'm facing
at work or home sort of is able to to go
under the undercurrent and then when i
step out a room i have a different frame
of mind and i can approach
the challenge in a different way
collectors need to
have more interaction with each other
because
i know
i know a few collectors out there they
happen to be friends but i'm sure there
are other people out there that have
better or different kind of collection
i'm always trying to see whether i can
meet up with them because i think
we share the same passion if you're
going to display them in this kind of
manner
and only you see it i think it's a bit
of a shame right so for me i always
anyone that wants to come in and see i'm
happy to invite them i also feel like
there are people out there that have the
same kind of mind frame it would be nice
if we can have a like a collecting
community
gathering where
we can we can sit down and like like
visit each other's home
[Music]
you